si maintenant officiel après avoir
remporté la direction de son parti
Daniel Smith entame aujourd'hui son
mandat comme première ministre de la
liberté un mandat qui sera guidé par 5
grandes valeurs qui souhaitent établir
dès le départ
au-delà des principes d'ailleurs Smith
demeure motivé par les mêmes idées
autonomistes tout comme son prédécesseur
Jason Kenny la nouvelle Première
ministre Albertine sera aussi
responsable des Affaires
intergouvernementales déjà des
confrontations se préparent Daniel Smith
veut de nouveau contester devant les
tribunaux la taxe sur le carbone même si
la Cour suprême a déjà tranché en faveur
d'Ottawa
la nouvelle Première ministre promet de
se battre bec et Hong contre Ottawa pour
faire respecter les juridictions
provinciales mais dès son assermentation
et de expliquer une volte-face
importante à propos de son projet de loi
sur la souveraineté
plus question de ne pas reconnaître les
jugements de la Cour suprême comme elle
le promettait pourtant il y a quelques
semaines
même avec ce recul l'opposition continue
d'attaquer sans relâche la louange sur
la souveraineté les néo démocrate
demande maintenant à tous les élus
conservateurs de s'y opposés pour des
raisons économiques
internes pour les conservateurs albertés
et les défis sont nombreux c'est clair
que c'est l'unité du parti Daniel Smith
doit d'abord rallier derrière elle tous
les conservateurs mais la confrontation
qu'elle cherche tant avec Ottawa
pourrait ne pas avoir lieu le
gouvernement fédéral n'ayant aucun été
ré ajouté de l'huile sur le feu observe
cette expert on peut juste circuler du
côté de l'Alberta mais le levier je
hésique de la loi sur la souveraineté
pour être révéler finalement
plus symbolique qu'efficace pour Daniel
Smith le contre-la-montre commence dès
aujourd'hui avec des élections rien
prévu le printemps prochain elle devra
rapidement appliquer ces réformes mais
surtout regagner la confiance des
Albertins eux qui ont jugé sévèrement la
performance des conservateurs au cours
des deux dernières années ici Mathieu
Gohier Radio-Canada Edmonton